yeah this is a question that not a lot
of people ask what do you guys think the
foundation of a relationship is
i guess trust
um like with trust and communication you
can pretty much i feel like that's why a
lot of people are scared of probably
polygamous relationships because in
monogamous relationships maybe they
can't manage this trust and
communication and communication with
like one person one of the person then
to imagine with like multiple people can
seem quite complex i think that's why
it's probably um quite a scary thing for
a lot of people but i do see like it's
the future of like relationships i think
it's value-added to be honest i think
like everyone every relationship we have
right
like even just friendships it's the
value you bring to each other's life so
me and you right we become best friends
after this
every single day right like the value
you know you i would bring to you is
maybe i'm entertaining i'm very
entertaining i'm funny too
and like the value you would bring to me
is like you're good listener right i do
have a follow-up question yeah so so
every every relationship is an exchange
of value and it they start to go south
when like one part partner like doesn't
bring that
yeah and so but the the problem is men
and women value different things so it's
hard to be on the same page
it's not hard to be on the same page but
i think women are confused so like like
girls will make a lot of money and think
that's attractive to men but men don't
really care it's like nothing to them
it's like a shoe collection
like like if a guy has a shoe collection
or do you care no no like it's like
that's like our money yeah and so like
girls will make all this money and think
oh all these guys are gonna want me but
they don't they're like yeah it's
nothing yeah yeah i understand that i
understand how like sometimes women have
like like a false perception of what men
want yeah relationship and like men also
have like a full potential what women
want they're like like uh they want a
woman like a man thinks a woman wants
certain things that's but sometimes a
woman is like not even interested i
don't think you can go off of men and
women as i said before
human beings are all human beings and
we're all different
yeah not everyone is is um
not everyone is confident enough to be
themselves
not everyone even knows who they are yet
let's say people are 18 19 20 21 22 i
don't even believe i know bear in mind
like i do know the certain certain
things but like words like integrity i
don't think a lot of 18 euros have that
they might change
in certain
uh uh environments yeah but my follow-up
question question was
do you guys believe that love is uh
unconditional
no no
you don't because there's always
something you can do that will like you
can there's there's a lot of extreme
things you can do that will prob like
pretty much end a lot of like
relationships bear in mind i didn't say
relationship i just said love
yeah i don't think love is unconditional
right there's like phases of love like
when it's like at its peak and when it's
not
the only unconditional love is maybe
parent child and even i know and i know
people that hate their parents and
parents that hate their kids so i would
even say that's conditional
i don't know the closest thing i would
say to unconditional
the reason i said that is because
you were talking about what men and
women were in a relationship right
the woman will love you on the condition
that you do xyz
the man will love you on the condition
that you do xyz those conditions are
that man or woman's
uh perception of what a good
relationship is
does that make sense
yeah so that's why i said we can't just
say men and women because everyone's
different yeah so
let's say you don't you want a guy
that's shorter than you yeah and i know
you don't that's what i said
and that's that's all you want yeah um
these six ten six eleven guys coming up
do you seven foot guys coming up you
talking about
do you wanna join a date yeah you're
gonna let them know
but bear in mind like you
let's say they have everything else you
want
you're still going to say no because
that's the one thing that's the one
non-negotiable that you are not going to
negotiate like listen i don't shrink and
then maybe like yeah yeah negotiation
yeah at all so
like
for us to say
men and women we can't even
begin because every time i
listen to podcasts or hear these type of
conversations in my head i'm like
everyone's not the same because i've met
different type of guys i have different
types of one different oh oh for sure
for i think you talk about attraction
but we but we this is this is what i
always say on my podcast we can't we
would go all day if we talk about the
specifics we always talk about in
general and in general if a girl's
really hot she dates a rich guy and if a
guy's really rich he dates a hot girl so
there's something to be said but that's
the problem we can't go off in general
the reason why i'm saying that i don't
get twisted i understand why yeah but
the reason why i'm saying that is
because when we go off of general then
certain problems
will never ever be will never never come
to surface like what
for instance okay um
how liking a short guy like that was to
happen you're like
if that was to happen
like that's
do you know how many other girls out
there like probably have a secret fetch
for short guys but i don't want to say
it because no one else is saying it
actually that's a big thing of that's a
big thing in like in in in cell culture
i don't know if i'm not saying that you
know those guys who are like really like
demonized who are you know yeah um like
women like they like hate women or
whatever um
like that's a big thing where they're
like oh women have all these
expectations and stuff about men and
then they kind of warp their minds to
think
like that's a big thing like um that
they use against like weaponised women
yeah or like demonize them and feminism
well there is something interesting i
learned in psychology recently i did
like a couples therapy um like module in
my psychology course and basically said
that we look for people that give us
like the same pain or the most like if
we had a room full of people we would
choose the person to be a partner that
would give us like is capable of giving
us the most pain because we look for the
person that emulates the relationship
with our parents so a lot of our
attraction is not like always best
choice we don't always make like we
never really make the best choice i
think so we choose the person that
probably wouldn't listen to us the most
or have the most shared interests but
like fits the dynamic the emotional
dynamics
go off you not being educated enough
from yours like as like the type of
person you are because you haven't grown
yet i don't think it's like about
knowing yourself because i feel like
this isn't like a subconscious level
because like you're trying to emma like
like this emotional relationship that
you've had with like your parents i feel
like that's something that you can't
control but i think it's just
interesting
i think it's just interesting that
people don't
see i think they misinterpret that i
think women are attracted to traits that
are good and bad no like like it's a two
it's a two-dimensional thing right
because we're attracted to men that are
very that make a lot of money right or
competent right so that that comes high
in the trade disagreeableness
so if a guy's more disagreeable he tends
to make more money that's why men make
more money than women because they're
more willing to negotiate for better
salaries and women will just be like oh
okay you know because we're more
agreeable than men on average
but on the other side of that like
prisoners are also disagreeable
so we're attracted to the same trait
that like makes one person a successful
businessman and one person a prisoner
and and so a lot of like the traits that
we like
it's like it's
well yeah because we're attracted you're
you're biologically attracted to a guy
that has slept with like more girls and
we can't really help that because no
girl wants a guy that nobody wants
like like that's also for a guy
a guy would want a girl that nobody else
wants but he but he doesn't want a guy
that like everyone's had not everyone's
had but like you want people to find
your girlfriend attractive for sure for
sure for sure yeah yeah yeah there's
there's this interesting thing i heard
that's about sexual attraction and how
that's based off literally like
science-based it's based off like
what you want from your mate to out of
your offspring because obviously like
love and all that and like attraction
it's all just like chemicals to make you
shag like to have spring like like
apparently
sexual attraction is just
like you when you're sexually attracted
to someone you want certain traits in
your childhood that makes sense though
like if you see someone that's tall
you're like oh yeah he could care and
potentially oh yeah that makes like well
because you want the best like genetic
offspring especially especially women
like we want
we want like good genes
[Music]
well that's that's like the difference
because men
like historically they want it was the
quantity of women that they could
produce with and women it was the
quality of the gene yeah i think that's
also to do with like how long the woman
is pregnant before that the woman has to
take nine months to have this child it's
an investment no
why i think foreign birth control
changed the world and it changed dating
because
you have all these girls that are like
sleeping with a guy that they would
never get before yeah so like a girl
that's a four like a guy like a guy
that's eight nine or ten will sleep with
a girl that's a four five or six you
think like just because of availability
not not every guy right but like
just twenty percent no no i'm saying
like there's there's a good a good you
know look at tristan thompson he's out
here wild then like
nick kit you know what i mean like yeah
and so these girls like think they're
hot enough to like get commitment but
they wouldn't like i would never commit
to her it's just sex but then the girl
thinks she's above like guys that are
actually like on her level none of you
guys are saying this do you believe
that guy is cheap because of sex because
they're just odd
because of emotions or sex i think it's
like a biological thing i think there's
a lot of like i feel like a lot of
people have that like
you're not receiving the validation that
you need in your relationship so you
have to go outside to find something
that you're missing so i think it
happens in like a relationship that's
probably not stable or there's something
missing like maybe you're going through
something and you can't talk to like
your partner and you want to find that
emotional connection with someone else
or you're not having sex in this
relationship you want to find that
somewhere else something's like missing
from the relationship that you're in so
it's like you're not healthy so what if
you spot it again the guy was like you
know what i just wanted to have sex like
i love my girlfriend but i just wanted
to have sex what if the guy said that to
you i'm like that's a bit disrespectful
my yeah my personal thing is perfect
with the girlfriend you could like you
can always literally say like
what if we were
like polyamorous like what if we did you
know like say oh what if we want to tuck
up with different people
and then like at least have that
conversation but if you're
getting of other people and then lying
that's cheating that's wrong
if you don't even have that conversation
and then kind of and i think especially
with married people which is the big
thing that people talk about with
cheating is like married people and then
they cheat with people
um it's like you could have at least had
that conversation and it's been like
maybe if we were you know open and more
you know like
i think it's that thing of like if you
don't at least have that conversation
it's just like cowardly to me personally
no i i agree but i do think men and
women cheat different like i think i
think men
like i i think men are more able to like
just sleep with a girl and like forget
and just like it's just like just like
what what makes you think that because
they just because
what makes me think that because men and
women like you guys are programmed to do
that like like
genetically you guys wanted to spread
your seed as much as possible
historically
where women had to find the best quality
mate and so you know there has to be
like we don't just forget our genetics
overnight just because we have birth
control nowadays so how would a woman
cheat that's different to a man like
what's that how would you because i
think when a girl cheats usually the guy
is like better like like someone that's
like okay like tradition like films and
stuff like they'll be like a guy that's
maybe more successful yeah yeah where
the guy will like like i always say this
on my podcast when i when girls realize
they have to be like worried about the
ugly girls too
and it's true because because guys we'll
cheat with a girl they that's not even
they're not attractive
because you know like how many girl guys
do you know that cheated and you're like
he cheated with her
over because it's not about that for
like
yeah it's just about uh it's just a you
know i think it's you know
as a guy you should be open with what
you're trying to do but then most girls
can't handle it either